wow
[Music]
we are all domestic terrorists
ladies and gentlemen hell yeah brother
hell yeah
Raise Hell praise Dale baby we're
freaking back welcome everybody it's the
leftovers here to bring the culture War
back
to the Confederate okay I got right off
the bat I got some things to say
go ahead one
you look very skinny today thanks bro
thank you
I didn't sleep well I'm very tired but I
am feeling skinny I'm in the middle of a
second push right now uh-huh so thank
you for acknowledging that I like that
you talk about it like like you're
pooping like the well I feel like that's
something that you would use for for
[__] but anyway I'm in the middle of
a push uh Hassan give me a moment um so
that's one number two
I'm digging the Steve's Zoo like the the
the fuckboy beanie okay thank you it
looks good thank you no it's the regular
beanie I just like no I know I didn't
get the memo yeah I just rolled it up
that's my new thing hold on
yeah it looks good now that doesn't
stand your bald yeah it doesn't work for
you you can't do it okay you look like
you look like an unrolled condom no you
look like a like a
ottoman uh you look like a boy that the
Ottomans found in the [__] Balkan
Village and you're about to become a
janissary when you do it like that
yeah yeah okay what else so uh those are
those are the two things I just wanted
to say I I saw the beanie I saw the
beanie the other day when you were uh
talking about retrieving uh your six
hundred thousand dollars back 620 620
five percent that matters
um five percent is everything yeah and
five percent
and uh I saw your beanie I was like damn
it looks good thanks
man thank you so much you know that
means a lot coming from from a hot dude
himself
thanks thanks real recognize real
apparently but if you were ugly it
wouldn't matter as much well no I
wouldn't I wouldn't I would say well
what do you know about being hot oh okay
you were like you know it's not your
fault hey Alfredo and Shredder are back
so we have a great episode today uh as
you guys know
the new Mario Brothers movie is out
lots of conflicting opinions but the one
more like Mario sisters I know right
well said
you're not ready we do know for sure is
that it's making a ton of money
and I hate that
because
anyway we'll I don't want to tease it
well the well also but the conservatives
conserva sphere is all tied up into a
pretzel trying to figure out why is it
making so much money is it because it's
woke or because it's anti-woke this is a
dialogue that's consumed them somehow
and it just goes to show you just how
obscene this this uh argument is when
they can't even agree yeah they can't
even agree no they definitely have a
definition for woke though for sure they
do they just they won't tell you it's
like Trump you know when they ask them
yeah well no no that's that's the real
definition I just meant like what
conservatives think is is woke is is you
know that's still up for debate but if
you ask them they'll tell you like I
can't tell you I know what it is but
let's have the debate now because I
think I'm gonna do you want to get
started on it like right off so we well
here's one yeah yeah yeah updates and
all this [__] well what do you what do
you have to say I mean you already
called me hot I mean what else is there
to say hahaha
you know um you want to ask me something
about you could compliment Hassan back I
mean look yeah he looks he always looks
good thank you
he always thank you very much you've
been you've been working out you've been
keeping on this I've been dude I've been
I've been going crazy with it
um I'm I'm almost I'm very close I'm
very close to like finally uh doing some
like full-blown shirtless photos again
oh my God by summer for sure like by the
time we get to like July I think I'm
I'll be there okay I'll get excited for
that and uh what is there any
consideration to doing the steroids yet
maybe mild steroids no no no
um that's like I'm holding on I'm
holding out on that until like the very
last moment like I have to until I like
you know you're saving that for when
you're a bit older and yeah yeah
impossible match science is gay
science is gay I'll have you know
uh well before I guess before we begin
the actual debate I of course as
Nathaniel uh klansman
Amma the belief that the Mario movie is
anti woke and that's why it made so much
money yeah I I am I am of the mindset
that it's definitely woke and you're
wrong what yeah you're wrong you're just
wrong about that how can we not agree on
something like this I mean it's like our
whole culture War type of thing should
be obvious
let's let's you want to do you want to
do it right now you are so excited I
don't even want to talk about like the
anti-walk beer or the Daily Caller no I
want to watch all this stuff but start
getting in character because well you
know I'm just gonna tell you right now
you have no shot dude Mario this ain't a
character nice and this is true that's
who I am this is who I am I'm driving
through I'm a I'm a country boy born and
bred you know I want to tell you
something actually on a serious note
what's up I was live streaming or doing
a podcast
and we were talking about uh
I don't know how it comes up from time
to time about how my old more reaction
not reactionary but social justice
Warrior content and a lot of people a
lot of people were saying
that they went down the conservative
kind of uh manhole and that because of
this show or because of my switch or
because of your show a lot of people are
coming around
and I I didn't know what was the actual
effect if it was doing anything or not
but it's nice to see that
it's nice to hear that there's a lot of
yeah for sure
the one thing I heard of consistently
was that I've been watching you since I
was like in middle school and as a 14
year old boy I started seeing like Ben
Shapiro owns feminist videos and then
that's what got him down throughout the
whole thinking Crowder and Ben Shapiro
were awesome but literal 14 year old
boys I thought that was interesting oh
for sure I mean you see the way that
they post so embarrassing though like
now they're they're doing it again
that's like there's always a new crop of
14 year old boys that are becoming 14
yeah and they gravitate towards like any
kind of like anti-hierarchy edgy content
and commentary that they find to be
subversive disruptive what they don't
really realize is that the commentary
that they're gravitating towards that
they find subversive is actually just
like the same [__] that their dad and
their grandfather believes you know what
I mean but right now that is already
happening you got no jumper you got you
know Adam 16 you got like all these
accounts like who's Adam
loud Adam 16 of no jumper Adam 22. are
you calling it that because that's the
age that oh Adam's 16 that's so good all
right oops Yeah I guess I had a oopsie
there sorry item 16. I thought you were
making an implications I'm only 16. you
know what you're talking about
um I mean he said it you got that you
you got those guys you got the Daily
Loud guys like rap TV like there's so
much reaction or comments and of course
the coolest and most appealing Dennis
Prager yeah well that those that's the
old way right like Ben Shapiro and them
are kind of washed the new wave of like
reactionary content is coming from like
what's your argument coming from like
the Pua commentary sphere the like the
women are
I just heard like a jet engine back
there what was that they're just it
seems like a vacuum okay I think like an
industrial vacuum oh good it's gone
anyway uh there isn't any so those guys
are the ones who are like basically
trying to radicalize or uh Captivate and
capture the market of like young boys
but I I just imagine because you know
Stephen Crowder fancies himself like a
stand-up comedian so I just love the
idea of him going to like do his set and
it's just a bunch of 14 year old boys
just like a bunch of kids in the
audience no I think his audience is like
a lot older I think Steven Crowder
well conservative commentary usually is
like
very uh like the people that go into the
commentary and actually care about the
politics on the conservative side are
going to be older the conservative base
is older the conservative base is richer
um so so those are the those are not the
guys who are watching like the change my
mind anti-sjws uh or sjw's own
compilations the httw own compilations
are are all encompassing that's usually
how like a lot of 14 year olds like dip
their toes into it and they might become
like ideologically motivated and the
more they the more they watch that
content the more they gravitate towards
that the more the further down the
pipeline they'll go
um and then before you know it they're
in a Discord Splinter Cell leaking you
know government documents
CIA documents well okay so anyway in
between screaming and things medic slurs
and shooting guns and stuff the whole
never sinks far enough
but um uh I just want to Pat ourselves
on the back a little bit so thank you to
us
yeah yeah we did it so let's talk about
Mario
um so 427 million dollars it's made on
opening weekend which I think might be
the first or second most uh animated
movies ever made
uh it's certainly the top this year I
saw I don't know about I think it's all
time bro top that's crazy money
427 million opening weekend dude the f
that is pretty nuts our sense opening it
had the third biggest U.S premiere of an
animated film ever um but if you include
the worldwide
um it might it might actually get up
there what was one or two uh number one
is the uh Lion King the recent Live Well
new line the CGI uh lion dude that's a
bunch of woke garbage bro wait I thought
that was that movie I never even saw it
I thought it was dog [__] hell no it
made 191 million at the domestic box
office on its opening weekend a bunch of
woke [__] dude for sure
um and then number two is uh Incredibles
2.
wow what's number one
Lion King's number one yeah one
Incredibles Tuesday I'll have you know
the soundtrack to that movie uh-oh which
one the Lion King oh dude that's woke
that's automatically oh that's so true
oh so Mario is number one worldwide how
about that you you okay I dude yeah
Elton John is gay that's crazy amazing
I'm defending that it's woke right
you're saying you're saying that it's
woke and it's trash because of that okay
good good thank you uh just just want to
make sure real quick also neither of us
have seen the Mario movie yet right in
fact I don't think I don't think that
anyone here has seen it okay good I was
gonna go to the premiere and I I didn't
because it's woke yes that that part is
strong I was actually supposed to go to
the premiere I thought that the premiere
was a week before like we got ready I
was like oh yeah I'll take my brother to
this and then I realized like oh [__]
it's actually next week so then I never
ended up going for the premiere I'm
going this weekend with my son his first
movie ever are you're not worried
that it's going to turn him trans yeah I
am a little bit you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna queer your child
hopefully the uh popcorn and the drinks
and stuff will distract them enough well
don't worry Ethan you're arguing that it
is it is based in red pilled right um so
it's actually going to red pill so it's
ethical ethical consumption for your for
you and your child well so let's get
let's see here here's an album of right
wing YouTubers celebrating
its success as
anti-woke Mario Bros is the worst movie
in history insane critics roasted so
here he is defending
uh this master wait a minute is that is
that quarter pounder this is yeah wasn't
he defending another thing earlier this
week
someone getting uh ripped off by an MCN
oh yeah I know it
it was a quarter pounder with the
sometimes he comes through this is dude
he comes through you know oh now I must
defend Ethan Klein it is one of the most
difficult things I have dude he's such a
Merc like he is a mercenary he doesn't
he it's so obvious that he's just like
straight up saying whatever he thinks
like other neck bearded dudes like him
want to hear he's a fan we actually know
this for sure
yeah he's a he's a [__] fupa Trooper
bro I'll piss in the basement with you
dude let's do some members only content
cross streams in your basement didn't he
have
a a sort of uh
a sort of enlightened uh trans take a
while back that all of his fan base got
really mad at him for no I think you
think I think you're mistaking him with
another bald bearded man woke star oh
and he was just trolling wait no was
woke start trolling yeah he's like uh
controlling death to trans people wait
he did a call with uh cat falls I
thought no no no no he literally said
that what like the second in command
that drama alert is actually trans and
they started working their best
transition
I don't know there's I know and nobody
works there
no no the person who like I guess the
does his like social feeder or whatever
okay who sources all the material no
because recently he said he actually
came out and defended uh Chris and was
like it's so crazy how many people are
just like aggressively
out a tweet saying people are canceling
Ethan for yeah yeah you have to
understand he like yeah that that's
different that is irrelevant I like walk
star I'm drunk anyway here here so I
don't know he's still a piece of [__]
don't get me wrong he could just be like
an you know surprisingly not transphobic
and still be a piece of [__] on every
other issue
I don't think he's as un as surprisingly
not transphobic as you think no I think
he's like well he had this call with
keffels that was apparently like a total
disaster well and it wasn't that long
ago I say like this I I think he is
less transphobic than you would
immediately assume he is okay you know
what I mean we're like my assumption is
he's like uh you know like oh yeah trans
people are you know mentally ill type
person like that's what I that's my
assumption but it seems it's more like
it seems to be more like yo maybe we
should like ease up on the on the gas
pedal a little bit on on how much we
attack trans people like what the [__]
going on I know a trans person they're
fine or like my 18 year old girlfriend
is woke uh you know what I mean so I'm
learning more about trans people because
of that I like it anyway I mean listen
if if dating is 18 year old is what uh
gets him uh education then I'm all for
it
[Music]
I don't know what's this channel yellow
flash
oh it there are so many of these I was
shot when I was looking for these last
night all all of these channels that
you've never heard of before they're
they're all quartering clones they're
all like uh late 30s mid 40s a white guy
with the beard in a room full of toys
just like the quartering and they all
have like 500 000 Subs I don't get it
like you shouldn't you be embarrassed
you should be embarrassed they're
getting paid like way more than they
would make but even then you should
still be embarrassed like you're you're
presenting yourself if you're right wing
it's all about Aesthetics you got to
present yourself as like Macho figure
look at the quartering his success
defies all laws he's like the embodiment
of a of a soya of just like I mean yes
his whole Essence is still I think I
think that's because a lot of people
look and act exactly like him on the
right so they're like oh he's just like
me for real type [__] you know okay so
anyway this guy yellow flash Mario Just
exposed critics you guys make him gay
woke media has meltdown over the Super
Mario Bros not including
lbgt content did he met the letters are
mixed up they're a little mixed up but
oh my God there's a there's a war going
on woke Elites get destroyed after they
trust Super Mario Bros hilarious
backlash and Chris Pratt seems to be uh
the hero yeah he's he's saying [__] me
elude that's right
Midnight's Edge
Super Mario Bros humiliates Disney
an establishment critics by rejecting
wokeness dude y'all I mean it's like
this is such an expose on this whole
system
it's so nothing to do with wokeness that
they can't even agree on it and they're
still pumping out these videos based on
like the thinnest [__] broke it is
literally the Super Mario Bros okay
like
like this is not a character that is
known for even speaking okay
um the idea right that the idea that
like this has like uh you know
legitimate well thought out ideological
underpinnings is so silly it's as far as
like the age-old Trope of like uh you
know a man saves the princess or
whatever I think what was it that was
the that was the original argument day
like gamergate uh weirdos [__] hated
right what was it who who did that
originally Anita sarkisian
is that her name oh what did she
actually make a thesis about how Mario
yeah yeah yeah and like that's why
everybody [__] that was one of the
many things like 50 years old to be fair
like the the reality is it's just it's
just super old school and not in a not
in like in any serious like ideological
way uh there are I think literally
Nintendo's very weird with this but they
have like actually trans characters and
stuff sometimes they like hide in plain
sight oh even you wouldn't expect it
from like a Japanese company that's like
that was you know that started in like
1881 you know what I mean but they do
they do that sometimes
um but other than that it's just like
it's just a movie man it's just a movie
like I say this to liberals who
constantly [__] look to like their
content consumption to make sure that
they're moderating it make sure that
it's like actually ethically good when
you have good characters doing good
things like I tell them to shut the [__]
up and calm down and I will uh you know
bring that same energy yeah there it is
Alberto
um and I will have that same energy for
conservatives that also try to do really
bad
media analysis it's just bad faith it's
not even bad it's like they you know
what I mean not enough whoa critics slab
Super Mario movie
if you guys are looking for a job just
start doing this man it's easy money
no no no tell people that there is just
as much money to be made on the other
side you won't stop don't say that
there's like two there's like two
successful or maybe three successful lib
shows on YouTube and they're not that
successful either yeah no nobody's
getting 50 million deals although
although and then turning them down
Pac-Man's been crushing it lately it's
kind of crazy yeah I mean but like
yeah no do this but see if you want to
make money like Dave is like a he is
like a Social Democrat he still has like
liberal Tendencies You know what I mean
like there's no there's no equivalent to
this David is not like an extremist on
the left you know what I mean in the way
that like some of these [__]
extremely successful channels are on the
right like he's not doing the equivalent
of I heard him uh advocating for
marching south on the Confederacy just
yesterday
no like but do you see what I'm saying
he's like yeah I see what you're saying
he's just say normal he's like a sane
person let's kill people yeah he's a
sane person who who uh you know does
commentary and some of his ideas are to
the left of what is the norm in the
United States of America albeit it's
still very sane and still very normal
um and and even then like that's not the
equivalent to a guy who's like hyper
obsessively you know trying to follow
trying to figure out who's actually
trans even though they're like CIS
people in in media you know what I mean
that's like it's not a thing so as you
guys can see there's a ton of of uh
movement there on celebrating Mario but
are saying no Mario's woke But Here
Comes Stephen Crowder okay and they
don't need to do it one of the uh sweet
boys one of The Darlings of the right
here with Alex Jones no he has a
different opinion about no no Crowder
agrees with all these people you're
thinking that it's the next conservative
grifter though yeah so so opposite
position
so uh wait once again I'm saying Mario's
oh yeah Tim cool is the decident yeah
I'm saying Mario's woke yeah and and
Ethan is on the side of it yeah you're
Tim pool today bro I hate that yeah
you're Temple but better to be Tempo
than Stephen Crowder I guess castrated I
don't know about that
Temple at least he's he's like virgin he
like can't even get he like cries about
how virgin he is I don't so did Stephen
flexed about it he was I mean but
originally before he got married also
what do you mean Stephen Crowder is like
a deeply closeted man
who yeah but he probably manifests all
of that anxiety and anger and and it
turns it into a vector of hate you're
telling me he doesn't take a few days a
month down at the Motel 6 for
without too much to be uh perfectly
straight okay like I said if you work
out a lot that's pretty sus fellas okay
that's thus what are you trying to have
big old biceps for women they don't give
a [__] yet another reason why I am Alpha
that's right yeah all right so here's
Crowder you work out too much that's gay
that's gay dog you gotta you gotta stop
it you're not beating the gay
allegations
here's a Crowder anything with soccer
because it's already there and so the
Mario Brothers movie though by the way
this is a good example it's not even
necessarily uh anti-woke it just shuns
the idea of trying to be woke so
obviously the voice actor Chris Pratt
who's a known Christian I believe he's
more
he's out of the closet brother we're so
proud of you
it has a white Christian man dude
conservatives love portraying the idea
that like there is a holocaust style
situation happening for white Christians
in America like oh he's so brave for
coming out as a white Christian man in a
country that was built by and still run
by predominantly white Christian men
it's so so brave thank you oh yeah no it
is it's so brave and he's out of the
closet you know I'm sure he's gonna get
lots of [__] for being a white Christian
man but uh he's Brave and uh Crowder I'm
glad you're showing solidarity
conservative he said this he said this
is the soundtrack to your youth you
don't want someone to come along and
cynically destroy it I fully understand
that you do not want that to happen and
by the way critics did not like the
movie he can what the [__] bro so wait
he didn't even say anything wait what he
literally just said like he took a lot
of care and considerations like I used
to play Mario Brothers he's like there
you go he doesn't like trans people
because he's re he wants seems to be the
way they were
probably might not like trans people
let's be real right in his in his own
personal expression but that statement
your thesis is weak there buddy yeah
look at the contrast critics had 56
whereas the audience had 96 that I love
that that's never my favorite thing has
never happened bro this is my favorite
[__] thing that they people do it's
like wow look at us we're fighting back
against like the woke critics because
the audience score is like way higher
like dude dude review bombing still
exists okay I'm not even I'm not even
saying this is a bad movie I don't know
people that I do trust have said like
it's kind of mid that's what everybody
said yeah it's like it's like fine it's
it's bubble gum it's kind of mid yeah I
had high expectations for it though I do
like the franchise I I thought that it
would be good
um so I I am a little disappointed by
people saying that it was kind of mid
but
um as far as like the the movie critics
saying uh it's it's not good it's at 50
D6 and then the audience saying 96 like
that doesn't say anything it's like the
people that use Google Trends to be like
wow like a lot of people are you know
talking about abortion like yeah people
[__] Google that all the time that
doesn't you're not using it
appropriately like it doesn't mean
anything no hate what you wanted to mean
you can use it in whatever way you want
to this is insanely desperate let's read
a quote here from a Critic said it's a
fan service above all else regressively
so this is Eric Martin structure dude I
mean probably dumbass wait I think he
just means that like the movie sucks it
just went back it's going backwards he's
saying that the movie like you Crowder I
mean so full of the movie is just
slammed with fan service and nothing
more that's what he's saying which is
kind of funny because like as a Critic
you're doing critique on the Mario movie
no regressive means that uh it goes too
straight
Progressive is trans regressive is
straight yeah we're straight more gay
words what do they mean can they mean
different things under different
circumstances I'm Stephen Crowder and
this is what we're gonna get to the
bottom of today it's incredible though
they're really trying to prove this
thesis so much and there's just no
answering a thread bear story around
iconography linked to Source material
just isn't enough
it's a video game and by the way it's
not have you there you go see he's dead
at all it's a video game I mean it's not
it's a film based on a video game right
they're not rating
I think they're just doing like this
Mega straw man where they act like
everybody on the left is like pissed off
about this movie when there's it's zero
of it yeah I feel like everybody chill
lives it's just a movie
everyone's like I don't care
so there's that
um let's see But Here Comes Trouble in
Paradise
um
is this Tim Poole here uh-oh uh oh
Twitter has turned into a complete one
who the [__] is this guy this is uh one
of the people uh I think it was actually
the one that you were asking about just
uh no it was a difference Rises yeah
like he rises he's up he's up
listed this oh my God this guy took my
advice he's just quartering Junior it's
while if you're gonna emulate yourself
after somebody choosing the quartering
is like wild man it's the eighth pounder
um
today over the new Super Mario Brothers
movie that is coming out this weekend
and all of this has to do he goes the
Liberals are so triggered this movie is
coming out this weekend it's like dude
chill he's [__] this man is like
this man is the human embodiment of
triggered look at this with the Rotten
Tomatoes score this is currently
trending on Twitter because everyone is
calling out critics in the most
hilarious why do they all look the same
yeah
that's so weird
they all they all look like like a
mixture of like a guy who's not allowed
to be anywhere near a school and like uh
you know
like a like an operator like they're all
dudes that were medically ineligible uh
and and couldn't even do basic training
but then they like grew the beard out to
be like yeah yeah brother I love my
veterans
oh I love how frantic is from critics
with a 95 fresh from audiences the
critics have this to say while it's
nowhere near all right dude well good
for you man this guy oh only 30 000. so
here he's begging for Subs if you guys
want to help him I don't know help me
reach 400 000 Subs I mean I'm not above
that help the guy yeah
you know he's got good takes
uh uh not woke enough slams Super Mario
Brothers movie
here's another one
again they talk about
virtue signaling this guy's sitting here
in like a thin blue
clam shells wait what the [__] what is
he wearing dude this is The Thin Blue
clam show this is so awesome this goes
back to the usual dishes right this goes
back to my thesis that everyone
ultimately becomes a liberal like
everyone is a liberal at the end of the
day
neoliberal capitalist monoculture is so
pervasive it doesn't matter if you're
literally uh living in the mountains and
and then uh you know come down in the
Kabul or whatever or not couple uh it
doesn't matter if you're the Taliban it
doesn't matter if you're a [__]
right-wing guy who's like supposed to be
like ye ultimately everyone becomes a
Funko Pop collecting liberal
everyone what is this trying about like
you know media uh crying about like the
the politics in my media
not woken of critics slam Super Mario
Brothers it's literally not happening
uh but here okay now here comes the
conflict okay
bro you want to know this same dude wait
hold on you want to know what they're
doing right now what they're doing right
now is exactly what they did before
where like they would say if trans
people get to compete athletically then
like why couldn't a man just simply say
like well I'm a woman now and then
compete and because they couldn't find
like real examples of someone doing that
which would be cheating they wouldn't be
trans obviously right because they
couldn't find someone doing that then
they would go and do it themselves like
they'd be like I'm a right-wing
podcaster I want to you know build a
brand for myself so I decided to go and
compete in like the women's athletic
competition as a woman and guess what
libtard's own and it's like well you did
that you couldn't find someone who
actually does that in the wild so you
decided to be the [__] meme Steve
that's what they're doing now they're
like wait what the [__] is what is this
clamshell lives matter he's doing he's
got that hat you are so fascinated what
the [__] is it I mean I don't know I
don't know whatever I don't know what
I'm doing interpret what I'm looking at
there it looks like maybe Phantom of the
Opera merch it looks maybe like a like a
mask I got to know are they handcuffs
he's wearing the same shoes maybe
they're handcuffs maybe it's uh it's all
over his like BDSM he likes being pegged
oh it's all over he's got the bisexual
Lighting in the background like what's
going on man they all dude tough me
Daddy
he went and he got those take dog ads
the rgbs for The Tick Tock ads you know
like oh man so here is the same guy who
just decried it or celebrated it as
anti-woke
talking about it being too woke three
months ago you got to get your stories
straight Jack Peach just taking charge
Peach just taking charge stands up
right there like right at that moment
right there when I saw that I I was
thinking Bo Peep from Toy Story 4
um bro you're gay as hell
I'm so straight I don't even know what
you're talking about bro I see this
stuff it actually does radicalize me I
become one of those like Joe Rogan style
like uh you know what is it like strong
men uh make a good Society yeah yeah
yeah weak Society make men weak weak men
make bad Society bad Society get owned
by strong men like that that's what I
turned into I'm like go go die in a war
what are you doing like what are you
doing well the ukrainians need help
brother yeah
go deploy to Ukraine go deploy to
Ukraine stop talking about [__] like
why do you know the names of these
characters he's like ah Toy Story four
that's why he pulled out a Toy Story
reference dog like Europe what was the
character that's adult what's wrong with
you pull up the picture he just drew he
flew right off that he took that right
from the back of his mind bro at that
moment right there when I saw that I I
was thinking Bo Peep from Toy Story 4 Bo
Peep from Toy Story if you actually
loved it oh I know what it's going on
they had a whole culture more about Bo
Peep probably yeah just choose two girl
balls bro this is like this is like uh
you know you can't even enjoy the
commentary unless you read the Manga
like you need to know all 11 editions of
like prior culture warships
Bo Peep from uh Toy Story 4 was the
beginning in this long culture war of
making women not strong yeah hello I'm
the I'm the woke mind virus Defender uh
and and today I'm logging on to tell you
uh about my encyclopedia knowledge of
Toy Story and how many times I tried to
jerk off to Bo Peep and I couldn't do it
because God damn it the Patriots cannot
rise up
that's what they're doing to us you know
uh
I tell you what man if they only had
Peach doing like housework or something
so yeah it'd be a good movie you should
be sewing she should be set as you win
the long what are you even saying she's
not allowed to fight for her rights bro
no you're talking about when we get
invaded from China you don't want women
raising up arms what happened World War
II women can [__] ass [__] loser ass
clam shells lives matter bds7 people
pointed out it's his it's the logo of
his channel okay whatever I know what it
really means the cups when you that you
wear geeking gamer is that what it's
called yes indeed geeking Gamers yeah I
think we should bully nerds more yeah I
take it back someone was advocating for
that recently yeah I I was in a right
winger Andrew Tate or Aiden Ross and
then maybe I don't know they're saying
we need to bully people more like uh oh
it's fresh or fit oh yeah I totally
agree man I've been bullying you
non-stop yeah except when I make fun of
look at [__] hairline people are like
oh you're body shaming I'm like yeah I
am I'm doing that with the full
knowledge of what I'm doing I'm body
shaming him yes well then yeah I mean
it's a dose of their own medicine right
this guy lives by Body no it's just like
it's bad it's wrong okay it's bad and
it's wrong and sometimes I like doing
bad things that are wrong I just I'm not
a good person okay okay like I never
said I was fair enough I think we should
just be more open about that reality but
that's fair
and I sometimes like the body shame uh
those on the right for uh you know for
numerous of reasons because I want them
to feel bad yeah yeah yeah I don't know
I don't know what else to say it's not
honest
yeah so but again it's like World War II
was one uh in part thanks to the uh
empowerment of women but now it's like
Peach you got to put down that staff and
just let Bowser invade your kingdom and
rape and Pillager people and here's the
other thing Bowser here's the other
thing
there are there are games that I there
are things that I watch right and I like
and I do media analysis on it or like I
do like political analysis look at like
the political subtext like one piece is
one that I uh talk about quite
frequently but I like one piece like I'm
not gonna [__] turn around and be
like and make videos crying about a
particular anime that that has like
things that I don't appreciate in it you
know what I mean like
Call of Duty is a great example Call of
Duty is a video game franchise that gets
funding from the US military that
absolutely does propaganda for the state
Department's interests right they do so
much propaganda that they quite
literally took an American war crime the
highway of death in the Gulf War where
the United States bombed retreating
forces including men women and children
uh on this highway they stopped them
from they stopped them dead in their
tracks and they did like a multiple
day-long bombing campaign where they
eviscerated people right they destroyed
people men women children
and then in the new in one of the latest
Call of Duty games they attributed that
war crime to Russia in the [__] video
games awesome yeah like that's
propaganda that's good I still I still
enjoy the game I still do like criticism
but you don't see me [__] going like
why is this happening this is so [__]
up everybody remembers it's just like
this everybody remembers when Russia
dropped the nuclear bombs on Japan
the world changed that day that was so
[__] up of Stalin yeah it's just like
it's so stupid you can do media you can
do media analysis over like more adult
things okay like things that happen in
the [__] real world remember they're
entertaining bro what did I just
mentioned what year olds
they're entertaining eight-year-olds
they gotta speak to them I don't think
this is it for eight-year-olds man I
think it's for divorce dads that look
exactly like that guy that uh are
watching that and going this is why
Deborah left me this is why Deborah left
me because Mario's too woke or Mario's
not woke actually I'll tell you that
peach reminds me of my [__] wife
taking all kinds of taking all kinds up
getting a job
yeah it's goddamn getting a job having
her own income God damn hate that peach
[__] it's me and Mario Princess a
picture why don't you get the back in
the kitchen and making me a sandwich
what the [__] that's actually a quote
from the film
okay now I get what I like yeah yeah
thank God put down that the ax and make
a sandwich why don't you
um race Guy Walker
and she seems to dominate the rest of
the trailer Mario's the bumbling idiot
again if well you're oh are you not the
bumbling idiot by the way which is
you're very uncharacteristic of Mario he
was never portrayed as The bumbling
Idiot in any of the Nintendo games that
I certainly played I mean kind of right
he goes down she walks around and [__]
he goes down sewer pipes he's like
ducking his head down like a little like
beta mail
you know it's not he's just bumbling his
way he's like Mr Magoo really
so anyway here's where we get have fun
okay this is where the big fissure takes
place it's like if I watch this
and I got mad at it because it's like
upholding the monarchy because like the
main character Mario is a working-class
citizen and and a plumber and instead of
like being a blue-collar worker that
engages in like a proletarian Revolution
he ends up reinstating the monarchist
structures that are inherently
oppressive to the serves like true like
that's if I did that kind of [__]
media analysis people look at me go
you're a crazy person you want to know
why because that would be crazy to
[__] look at him goddamn franchise
like Mario and make something like that
our your fan base is not as desperate or
stupid to try to justify their shallow
and unjustifiable World Views so they
have to look for meaning in Mario
Brothers and Toy Story 4.
but here's Tim Poole now what's he doing
Tim pool comes against the Green
Mario movie is woke he's putting his
foot down girl boss Peach is invincible
and Mario is incompetent conservatives
are wrong he says you guys got it all
backwards
uh this this video is actually getting a
ton of hate because he I love this man
you know
let's see Tim uh the studio originally
had a far more girl boss storyline okay
good they toned that down Nintendo
forced them to tone it down and Elevate
Mario okay thank God
according to God thank God how do you
know that they know that
I'm not sure about this one Mario's
first mission would probably be a
challenge for him oh see now they're I
love that Mario apparently in the movie
had a really hard time on his first
Challenge and you're like bro what would
take you time to learn how to jump
through Mushroom Kingdom too
they literally saying [__] like that
Mario isn't stupid in the movie he's
inexperienced there's a difference he's
thrust into this world he knows nothing
about but overcomes that by the end Tim
foreign
this is one of those situations where
even if you're in the right just simply
describing it is frustrating like you've
you've been owned it's like a it's like
a Reddit debate you know what I mean if
you write a [__] paragraph on on a
subreddit doesn't matter if you're right
doesn't matter if you're wrong you're
wrong by default you've automatically
been owned If you defend the the ethics
of the Mario movie in either direction
you're just you're wrong you've lost
Mario isn't incompetent and Peach
Praises Mario for his masculine traits
and persistence and it sucks because
like I'm gonna have to end up doing this
now that's you well take it out peaches
just uh depicted as competent but her
immediate success she's embarrassed
about like a good woman should be and
she is more impressed by Mario's
persistence through failure no way does
it say that it's like a good woman
should be oh my God I made that up but
he says but her immediate success she's
embarrassed about which is like what the
[__] that's a feminine trait Mario is
incompetent he's weak but him being able
to Triumph despite his weakness is the
message of the story now we are in in
some way you are wrong in some ways I
think
um you know everyone has become a baby
they want to keep being a baby
they want to live like a baby right and
this is what happens there like this is
some baby [__] okay well this is a 30
minute video
um on the one on the one hand you know
everyone is a baby on the other hand
everyone's becoming like uh you know
they're becoming like medieval peasants
where they think like uh you know
like there was that there was a tick
tock video of people being like Oh How
can the mirror see the egg behind this
piece of paper it's like basic
Elementary science like third grade
science about how light reflects how can
the mirror see the egg have you not seen
those I haven't no it's just we are we
are like unwinding Society in especially
in the Western World especially in the
United States of America like we are we
are slowly but surely uh and and perhaps
deliberately making people actively
dumber and dumber and dumber in each
generation I don't know what you're
talking about this is glad this uh High
uh Academia analysis
okay let's see can anyone explain how
does this mirror know that there's an
object there can anyone explain how does
the mirror 2.7 million [__] likes on
me what no this person is trolling
how does the mirror know there's an egg
there first of all they think like no
this is literally like you're like a you
you are like a a like a medieval uh
peasant at this point you're like I'm
alone a mirror knows he's magic
this is a trolling right no it's not uh
Oh Boy Something Told me the mirror uh
hold up is the top comment yeah
well because of the government
it's like we have crippled but don't
mute them oh that's you this is Army
that's me okay yeah George W bush has
left all the children behind Okay Ronald
Reagan who are responsible for this you
[__] monsters
conspiracy the Democratic party is also
responsible for this with their [__]
advocacy for Charter Schools since the
90s you [__] animals how do deers
work bro bro
ears are like crazy I mean our eyes are
just mirrors for the universe or Jaden's
it's like I I had to literally do a step
by step of like explaining how light
explaining how we see things and how
like light reflects off of things and
then but even and then even unwind it
further by saying look there are certain
parts of the egg that the mirror quote
unquote can't see that your brain cannot
make up perhaps it has something to do
with I don't know light not being able
to hit that part
do you think that that could be a reason
why the mirror can see certain objects
or your brain can make it up versus uh
you know versus the other parts of the
object that the mirror can't see I don't
know maybe just think it through
[__] dude I'm I'm shaking man I can't
even think about Mario movie right now
all right so so enough of that thank you
so let's get a taste of temple Mario
Brothers movie has smashed a global
record this is a liberal team these
people on the right saying the movie did
it because it was anti-woke which is
really strange to me because the
narrative for the longest time was that
the movie was woke girl boss feminism
garbage I can't get over just like this
idea that a strong woman character makes
it woke like we're talking about half
the population of the world and we can't
have one strong female character it's
all girl boss woken it's like the [__]
you guys have moms don't you you all you
like you hate women that much you think
that little of women
that's very unrealistic depiction of
women I'll have you know
it's breaking my immersion hey if women
are so good how come I don't have a
girlfriend is what [__]
timely it's not my fault it's it's them
they are at their response behind the
paper now we've got another one and he's
showing a deodorant
crazy yo that's crazy no that's like
this is like a tick tock challenge I
gotta make one of those
how does the paper seem how does the
mirror see my balls behind the mirror
the paper
okay get back together spoilers ahead
because I went and saw the movie and uh
spoilers
oh God turn it off turn it off
when I saw this tweet from Stephen
Crowder he says the anti-woke Super
Mario Brothers movie he's going he's
opening a war with Crowder it's the
opening Salvo baby there's a war Brewing
has there been a riff between them since
the
and Tim was mostly backing up Crowder
during the whole uh Ben Shapiro split
that happened a few months ago so I
think they're on friendly terms it's
just a weird Hill to die on he's like no
this is where I'm gonna have to throw
the gauntlet well Tim it sounds like Tim
went and saw the movie which it didn't
seem like Crowder had so I I trust his
uh opinion more in the Crowders yeah set
a global record I thought to myself I
don't believe Stephen Crowder has
actually seen the movie and when I saw
this tweet I thought to myself
well the first thing I thought was is it
really anti-woke well it's weird because
all I've heard about it is that it is
woke right
perhaps the issue is conservatives don't
want to admit that a woke film made a
bunch of money especially broke a record
when the narrative tends to be get woke
go broke well as I often say get woke go
broke is not a law but it's more of a
tendency it's not even true not there's
that is never no there's no correlation
oh my God this makes me so mad as you
know go won't get broke is mostly right
there are exceptions from time to time
it like AKA it's just your theories you
know what it is it is so entirely
removed from reality in either direction
okay that's the [__] that's the
that's the main thing Chick-fil-A is a
perfect example of this okay if you make
a product that people want to eat if you
want to consume it don't matter people
are still gonna [__] consume it okay
it doesn't go in either direction it's
not because it's like anti-woke that
people are consuming it or because
Chick-fil-A magically became can't woke
and people are zooming in they don't
give a [__] most people don't consume
content like this only hyper obsessive
online politics [__] weirdos think
other human beings consume content like
this and then they try to tell you this
is how people are consuming content or
consuming products that's not how this
[__] works and I know it's weird of
me to say this because I'm a hyper
obsessive online political [__]
weirdo speaking to an entire audience of
hyper obsessive online political weirdos
as well so it's hard for us to see
outside of our little bubble that we
have crafted here but that is the
[__] reality okay that's it
I also love that depicting a man is
incompetent is uh
is uh woke it's like Tim look in the
mirror buddy no this is you see your
homies quarter in I mean I hate to tell
you this is what they did for years and
years like the this is the exact same
thing they've become the ant they've
become the sjws that they [__]
constantly criticize that's it that like
they would always say like oh really
like [__] oh wow having a bad
character be like an anti-hero in a
movie is a Bad Thing shut the [__] up
libtards it's a good movie I'm gonna
keep watching it whatever now they're
doing the exact same thing on the
opposite direction well what's funny is
I don't think liberals care at all about
this we're not and then they just have
to set up this straw man there was a
time and place and I think liberals do
not know I don't think they care about
no I think the the pendulum swung in the
other direction but under the Obama
Administration especially when like uh
this this feeling of powerlessness uh
LED people to basically reshift their
focus on uh you know making culture more
sanitized and it wasn't all that big of
a deal even back then but you know that
was a that was something that that
created momentum like oh a comedian said
an anti-asian joke like we should fire
him like the what was it [__] what's
his face uh Last Week Tonight or not
Last Week Tonight
I don't remember I don't know it's just
ultimately ultimately it's a it's a uh
an old attitude that what that we
basically left in the past people don't
actually do that uh as much anymore even
though every now and then it will uh
every now and then there will be
uh some kind of momentum beyond Behind
like uh you know boycotting Hogwarts for
example which is a abject failure like
it was it was always going to be a
failure because people completely are
removed from it like they don't even
think that there is uh anything
associated with uh transphobia in the
product itself that they're consuming
they just want to go to [__] Hogwarts
and feel good again like they're kids uh
so it's just not gonna happen and
liberals don't do it as much but
conservatives do it more now
all right let's do this and let's get
into the debate
Tim go ahead finish when you're dealing
with one of the most popular pieces of
intellectual property in human history
Mario Brothers it's bound to make a
bunch of make a bunch of money
seriously I didn't I went to go see the
movie because I think it is particularly
culturally relevant now to be honest I
didn't really want to see the movie a
little bit I like Mario I grew up
playing Mario I mentioned this
interested in seeing how they could do
this movie considering back in the 90s
they made some weird
weird movie so warning spoilers no but
I'll just say it right now after going
and watching the movie I would say in a
scale of one to ten in terms of how woke
the movie is I'd give it a six
I'll give it a six meaning I give it a
six folks all right so there it is we've
got opinions all over the board now I'm
of the opinion hey awesome
I'll tell you what brother
I heard that Mario movie is awoke or
wait no it's anti-wolf we love Mario I
love Mario let me get that hack someone
grab me the Hat I love Mario man tell
you what brother listen Nathaniel you're
absolutely wrong on this let me tell you
normally I love your commentary like how
you should be able to [__] your cousin
your first cousin absolutely brother
Lucy for child Brides absolutely brother
you age is just a number you and I are
gonna diverge my friend okay he's so
cool right
all right well well you why don't you
tell me why you wanted Mario
[__] what am I what am I supposed to
it's woke right yeah yeah you're welcome
Yeah Tim pool's uh attitude is is your
attitude yeah the Mario movie
is what
why let me tell you why yeah
they made our boy
first and foremost
they made our boy Mark Mario
into an Italian POC
okay I'm sick and tired of the pro
Italian agenda
they thought they could get they thought
they could pull a fast one on us and put
big beautiful woke
muscly man Chris Pratt as his voice and
I thought to myself maybe he's gonna
have a accent that's reflective of my
values that I want to see on screen but
no
I'll tell you what running around saying
this to me and Mario he's kind of like
one of them good Italians like them kind
of Mussolini Italians that we love kind
of like the way they do things you know
he's like a Godfather type of Italian no
I don't like that I don't like Italians
in my media
there's too much POC everybody knows and
then there's women
and then there's green characters again
where are the white characters let me
put it let me put it this way to your uh
let me put it this way I'll Checkmate
you right now Mushroom Kingdom
ain't one black person
ain't one black person and Mushroom
Kingdom amen that's that okay well very
mad no it's anti-working that's a that's
a diversion to make you forget that the
real cultural battle lines being drawn
in the Mario movie is against is about
men and women men used to be plumbers in
this Society men used to be able he is a
plumber boy
and all this show is doing
all this Show's doing is teaching you
and your kids that women can defend
themselves women can go out and and uh
you know defend themselves against other
people like uh like the like the turtle
guy well well let me tell you that I
don't like that Mario has to defend her
I'll tell you what not herself my
grandmammy she used to hit down Turtles
come up on the poach like and she had to
wish get him away with a broom and
sometimes a shotgun so my mama my grand
Mama they was out there stopping all
them Turtles and all that kind of stuff
I was just a boy they protected me from
the wildlife and they made me feel safe
like Peach making me feel safe now but
you say your grand Mammy my grandmother
protected you a man I was a child at the
time I'm protecting you a man a Boy
Child let me tell you this uh we you're
woke
you're woke too that's what I've learned
about this I'm learning so much about
you Nathaniel well I'll have you know
that once Nana told me once I found out
Nana might be a lesbian I pushed her
down the stairs good
okay we
but uh I'll tell you what man you wanna
talk up you want to talk about Peach
I'll tell you that woman looked good in
pink boy she ain't wearing no kind of
jeans she ain't wearing no kind of like
lesbian kind of shirt like with no but
that one's with this you're wrong the
rich Bros just hold on now you're wrong
I tried to jerk off the Princess Peach
so many times Nathaniel I tried and then
you know the the security came over woke
police came over said oh sorry what are
you PV hermanin in the [__] theater I
said to them sorry I have to do this for
America I have to jerk off you were
masturbating in the theater as is my
god-given right I don't believe that is
your ride [__] you mean of course I was
masturbating in the theater am I
supposed to masturbate so you weren't
able to uh finish uh the side of peach
no and it wasn't because of the security
telling me I need to leave and you know
they caught me doing this last time at
Toy Story 4 and how I had to wear a fake
mustache to hide my identity all
Whimsical like oh was you was you
jerking it at that kind of Mumbo dump
without dirt a cowboy on top of a
Shepherd girl from Toy Story 4.
Nathaniel Nathaniel I jerk off at every
movie to make sure I remember female
characters are woke or not I tell you
what I remember we went to toy store
four we was both we was both the god out
together we did that with that whole
thing where we did the old we did all
those sweet potatoes yeah put a hole in
the bottom of the popcorn that's right
it's a tasty treat and you get the jerk
off in private I'll tell you what mate I
got extra butter that oil does work and
there boy nice and warm too isn't it oh
yeah the nanny State the Chinese
Communists can't stop me from jerking
off at movie theater and you know what
you what you know what my favorite thing
is what's your favorite eating the
popcorn afterwards hell yeah you ever
heard of a soggy waffle yeah what's like
that but with popcorn yeah the viscosity
helps the the popcorn go down your
throat it's like a special kind of
butter okay we we need to get back on
subject okay well if I'll tell you what
man that peach I'm sorry brother that
you weren't able to finish at the side
of peach but to me
she is a princess she is wearing pink
she ain't looking like no kind of less
peonic truck driver kind of thing and
I'll tell you what man there was a scene
in that movie where she leaned over and
I swear you could see kind of like the
upper thigh kind of type of place man
she got nice shaven legs boy no hair on
Peach are you crazy
ain't no hair on page that's the way I
like it I don't know about you to be
more revealing and her titties needed to
be larger Nathaniel I'll tell you what
that's what I'm saying if it wasn't it's
woke
damn titties went large enough yeah
it's woke and I'll tell you what it did
well in the movie theaters and
there's you why because George Soros
brother that's right George Soros bought
all the tickets globally to make it seem
like you can't when you go woke you go
broke George Sora said nope I'ma make
sure that I'm paying for the the box
office tickets and and uh you know teach
all the children globally I'll tell you
that does make a lot of sense because
I've seen buses coming in about and I
saw this movie about like 10 p.m not bro
popular time and I've seen all kinds of
buses coming in with black people
looking folks we're busting in
Guatemalan migrant children right they
was filling up the whole theater right
the watch the the watch the movie do
something went right with that theater
yeah and they came out those those
Guatemalan migrant children came out
right out right back into the Caravan
going to a white neighborhood I know
they they all preach gender non-binary
queer all right but hold on hold on I'll
tell tell you it's anti-woke not just
because there ain't no black people
which I do like but because
again Peach she is a princess she is a
queen she is up holding capitalism she
is a capitalist icon she collects coins
she collects power-ups she is a
capitalist and she is accumulated him
wealth like a good American Queen she is
I like I like where you I like that I do
agree with that I do I am a big fan of
the monarchy But ultimately she's doing
what I hate which is called girl boss
yassified feminism uh that's yassified
capitalism I hate that I want capitalism
to be men I understand men only she
should be in the kitchen instead of
trying to save herself instead of being
in a position of power wouldn't you say
you want to know what the most woke
country on the planet was England why
they had a queen they kept saying yes
Queen yes Queen that's right I don't
remember that I'll tell you what man
changed dramatically what the queen
became Queen the queen oh tell you man I
agree with you but there is one time a
woman can't defend herself it's when
she's attempting to be raped by a big
kind of turtle kind of thing named
Bowser she allowed to defend herself and
that's that ain't good that ain't girl
Boston that's just good sense boy no and
that's bestiality although I do lack
bestiality at times so I don't know if
I'm gonna do it well you ain't well well
me and the boys
got a problem with that sometimes you
get real horny you live in you don't
know what it's like to be living in a
rural area where there's no women around
Diane went down to the city damn damn
you ain't don't act like you ain't never
got cozy with a cow before sometimes you
just wonder what it feels like there
ain't no goddamn drumming around there
I'm close and personal with a donkey a
donkey a cow ain't no bucket required
I tell you man I ain't never been with
when we get to a horny around the Age
15. Ain't No Woman No Woman there my
Grandmama
and I tell you come up right on Cowboy
they sleep standing up make it easy come
up right there give it a little feel get
up up down back back there and you know
you know just to get ready for like when
the real thing happened so us boys used
to go out there was one cow named Sally
we should line up take turn run the
Train on deer salad she's a good old
steer boy good old Suey tell you she was
real tight too for a cattle you don't
expect them to be nice to talk because
it's so big and heavy but I'll tell you
man she was good she was tired right we
line up and I just bla I'd finish boy
because you know she ain't getting
pregnant or nothing she ain't got no
STDs ain't no cow AIDS so we line up our
bust thinner than my friend Buckley come
up behind me it's his turn he busting
her too we just live filling her up
and I'll tell you the next day they come
out and milk that cow and a little bit
of there'd be a little bit of a not just
milk coming out of two holes if you know
what I'm saying it's a little vulgar but
it is what it is and I'm a better lover
for it
let me tell you something on my wedding
night hessing I was a better man for it
I'll tell you my wife was one happy
camper right there thank you to Sally
this is falling off the railing brother
it's fine it's falling off the rails and
that's it look all I'm gonna say is this
okay
my favorite
content creator on YouTube
is the the not templarged channel uh not
watch okay it used to make medieval
videos about armor and he was a history
nerd and then he decided to take on a
much stronger battle okay he decided to
take on woke culture in the woke agenda
and I love him for it okay I love him
and he made a one hour 25 minute 27
second video
on the Mario movie I mean the Mario
movie run time is half the [__] I
mean he made hat he he almost made the
made the entire movie okay
and let me tell you his review all right
okay these are the points that you
cannot address now I haven't seen the
movie and I know you haven't even I
ain't seen that movie I ain't seen that
that's right I ain't seen but but who
gives a [__] because our audience is
watching because they're all so [__]
stupid I ain't watching that yeah
and let me tell you he said Super Mario
Bros review
Paige is a girl boss Yaks yeah Bowser is
a simp ew and Mario is a punching bag
but that don't sound so good but let me
put it this way it's about let me put it
this way this is Mario's one of Mario's
enemies you know what that is what is
that that's a
that right there is an e Islamic
terrorist character and I'll tell you
mario'll be out there stop him he
putting out bombs like that excuse me
this is my opportunity to explain he's
out there like that Kiefer Sutherland at
24 putting out bombs and destroying
terrorists he's a good American Patriot
agent look at this hey is this not a
terrorist he's throwing bombs out there
and everything he got his head covered
where are we wearing black where was 9
11. this goddamn Turtle like you
remember a Isis
where was bomb bro on 911 let me tell
you bomb Bros Aces agent as well I'll
tell you why that's welcome that ain't
woke brother no it's woke because back
in the day
you know they they would give him a like
a like a Mojo hadine style name you know
but they won't do that no more it's I
don't even know what What ethnicity that
turtle is you know what I'm saying
that's right right that's why it's well
they're trying to hide the truth that's
that's a good point brother he should
look more Arabic yeah instead he don't
even have no beard or distinguishing
Futures I'm a [__] dumbass I need
that but I got Jeff Dunham Carter he's
funny but they got a they got a wink at
us and give us kind of soft signal
that's why he on black like kind of like
a robe like Isis no he's not got a mask
I can't make that distinguishment I'm
telling you man I'm telling you man bomb
bro did not 11 and that ain't all he's
still out there boy and Mario down them
again Mario locks CIA hunting them down
I'll tell you something else because you
think you're so smart let me ask you
this brother what color is Mario's hat
[Music]
go ahead answer the question
answer the question brother
please what color is his goddamn hat
Nathaniel this right here no is a Maga
hair no I've been Maga before Maga
you're right hey guess what that AM
stand for Mike Mega make America great
God damn it and that's why we going
after Isis
I love it God damn it you're right I'll
tell you man all right it is anti-woke
man there ain't no white man walk around
in that red hat with an m on it who
ain't Maga you're right you're right
brother yeah
come on
thank you you owned me sir I thought I
had you had no black people to be honest
you got more yeah well Chris Pratt he's
a good old boy I don't know if you know
that that's right I mean he's right
you're right about that he is a good old
boy I mean he's a Christian which is
very difficult to be in America nowadays
you know much more difficult than
anybody else hey I'm surprised they
didn't get that kind of like Hunter
Schaefer to play Mario that's what I was
expecting but they got curious prayer
and that's what I appreciate that's why
they meant not anti whoa I heard there
was a man I hate Hunter Schaefer I'm
always I always see photos of her
looking sexy on my timeline and I'm like
damn she's so hot and then someone tells
me oh that's 100 Shavers you trans woman
I say oh no I'll tell you that hunter
that Hunter Schaefer make me feel all
types away hold on we're having a
technical issue oh we got a technical
issue can y'all fix that or is that like
a technical issue it's a technical issue
okay hold on just a little technical
issue here we have some technical issue
it sounds like we do about it what are
we gonna do
[Music]
Stars anti-woke
I hit the button wait why I don't know
but what
after everything that was just said that
was what you bought what did you say no
not that one that was fine right yeah
yeah it was all fun whatever let's move
on
the Bun's never a bad idea
let's not talk about it
I don't think you said anything wrong I
don't either I don't either I was just
being cautious okay all right you know
fair enough yeah we'll move on
just being cautious what happens when
you hit the button because the race is
the last 30s yeah the last 25 seconds
that just occurred whatever that was
will be so can you button twice yeah
yeah
he was just
I saw yeah I don't this is a this is a
misfire
but I I'd prefer yeah it was a misfire
but I prefer to be
I prefer to be honest I I like that I
appreciate that yeah you are you are
overly cautious it didn't need to happen
but it's cool that you did it right
yeah
that's it brother I'll tell you what man
that Mario is kind of like an anti-walk
hero
I'll tell you what he does all kind of
Plumbing like a good yeah you want to
know what the most woke part about it
was what's that the Rainbow Road
okay I got no defense for that Rainbow
Road man I saw rainbow the other day
after the you know after the the the the
Chinese rain clouds were creating
rainbows left and right immediately went
down to the truck stop went to the
nearest glory hole like a fine right
hahaha
[Music]
what why are you doing why'd you do it
again you guys are making me feel like I
said I didn't dude you were popping off
about [__] a cow in great deep but
that's not offensive okay
the woke Vine virus has infected you
Ethan well well I'm anti-woke and you
never know everything stands for both
Dan and I would ever agree that you yeah
being overly cautious retired today so
my decision making is a little okay all
right but what can I do
I don't know what's left of that we cut
out a whole minute of it okay but there
we go I think I took the dub
[Applause]
wrecker is mad you're mad all right well
let's let's we don't have we've got I
guess maybe an hour I don't know let's
talk about some other stuff uh we got 45
minutes we really I think we covered
ground on Mario I think I think we have
discussed Mario that are we've talked
about Mario almost as long as the movie
yeah 70 minutes I think the movie's like
80. yeah now we have truly become
a right-wing media show yeah covering
covering something extensively that is
so
like uh irrelevant stupid
unproductive you know that is that is
literally the essence of being a right
winger we finally did it we're bringing
it back
oh my God look at this I just saw this
on uh this guy's Sunny V2 what's up
these video essays yeah he he I remember
sunnyv2 uh from the one time he did like
a video I've always been a little sussy
on in my watches videos from Tom and Tom
I think they're like very well edited uh
but he did a video on ninja maybe I
should watch it before I comment so but
I don't know
I think the button is interfering with
the audio for the record yeah I actually
just I was about typing to you oh no
since we came back from the second thing
the audio got all [__] up again so uh
we just bypassed it oh there's no button
so you are you are free balling once
again free balling baby show me there's
no button don't do it don't do it don't
do it yep that's not doing anything I
mean I'm not I haven't watched it but
here's a comment it says uh he boils
down Chris's transition to a business
decision specifically how it affects Mr
BEAST's brand sure I guess you could say
it's neutral point of view but it just
feels inhuman it's not a neutral point
of view it is inhumane like you're
that's insane you would never do that
about any other group of people it's
always people get away with saying
whatever the [__] they want about trans
people because one they're hyper
marginalized they're a much smaller
subsect of society and it is so
normative like it is the normative
normal position to just be like selling
yourself transphobic that like can you
imagine like
writing this exact same article about uh
you know someone coming out as gay
in the Mr Beast Universe if someone was
like uh I'm gay by the way whatever I'm
a gay man
um look can you imagine if anyone wrote
commentary like that you would be like
what the [__] are you talking about what
are you crazy what the [__] you're an
insane person apparently he describes
Chris as an over-the-top lgbtq character
I maybe we should watch this
I'm gonna I'm gonna end up watching it
later um if you want we can watch it now
but let's do it I'm into it I like this
uh Cutting Edge
drama
I feel like we got to defend Chris
wherever we can because this is about to
turn into like a big [__] nasty mess
and I feel like it's good for us to
support him whenever we can let him know
he got friends out here uh yeah uh it is
it has become that way it has become so
[__] insane like uh we know this
already if you're if you're shit's
getting a lot of views of course it's
getting a lot it's only nine minutes we
can do this because people [__] Lo
it's the same it's the same concept
behind like the Mario movie right
because rage clicks get a lot of clicks
ultimately people love the drama a lot
of people are transphobic they're like
oh thank God there's some some more
transphobic commentary oh it's my
favorite holy [__] let's hear what this
guy has to say and then it also gets
clicks from the other side people like
us that watch it to be like what the
[__] is this guy talking about is
[__] this sucks let's watch this the
Chris Tyson situation could become a
complete disaster for Mr base brand I
don't disagree with the premise right
because I know that a lot of his fans
are probably transphobic Ultra
conservative I don't even I don't even
agree I think a lot of his fans are
children and because a lot of his fans
are children they don't have any [__]
like immediate transphobic opinions on
the matter it's just about uh social
conditioning there is so many people
though like there are a lot of adults
however so many people who watch Mr
Beast I don't think anything could stop
him
not even being friends with the Trans
person yeah it's so however I also
provide some unique benefits so let's
begin by going over the drama before
explaining exactly how this will impact
the Mr Beast channel in mid-2022 fans
began to notice that Chris Tyson was
changing in the early days he
represented the quintessential Southern
gun and truck-loving dude I mean okay no
that no no that I mean this is this is
such a familiar story that I have
personally heard from my own fans in my
fan base that were like I used to
[__] hate you I was super transphobic
well I got breaking news what you just I
got this from my accountant you just
received 620 000 wire from BB TV today
wait it wasn't a 622 620
000 no 619 they gave me the extra K damn
the extra case everything oh we've got
the money everybody that's crazy crazy
holy [__] dude
hormone replacement for everybody we
watch hormones I got you
it's a party let's all go let's all go
trans like emperor ivanko
Empress Eva
what is that what is that I see oh God a
new cash a new cash
a new stimulus package for the h3s3
Production Studio I wonder
where could it go that could be so good
I'm not going to Japan it's stupid it's
too far oh that's interesting what did
you say personally I'm so woke I'm
against racial purity of Japan and I am
well wouldn't you be destroying the
racial Purity by going to Japan [__]
own Checkmate I don't live there they're
feeling my welcome it doesn't matter
even for a [__] argument I'm not
living there they let me come spend my
money it doesn't let me live there it
doesn't matter because what you're doing
is like slowly but surely showing
Japanese people that like Logan Paul
that that you know white is right that's
what you're showing
that that white people should be allowed
in to live in Japan all right I'm
surprised they didn't just shut down the
Border completely after suicide forest
they're like this was a mistake well
they they I think the Japanese
government slowly but surely is Coming
to Terms of the reality that if you
don't let any immigration happen in your
country you're just literally going to
be a nation of like 95 year olds
yo I just got 620k from BB TV let's go
music
I'm not going to Japan though well come
on
have you everybody's invited we can we
can do a video with PewDiePie
dude there's content there's some juice
juice let's go dude I'm not going you
guys don't have kids you wanted us to uh
we're gonna do like a thing where we all
pitch you on like our travel packages
yeah so obviously you know what mine
will be and I feel like
I already started thinking about last
night I feel like by the end of my
presentation you need Solutions
what's your suggestion where do you want
to go down pushing for Japan oh you want
to go to Japan yeah yeah you need to
pitch I was unfamiliar to my problem I
have two dogs and two young kids oh yeah
no I'll have that all right you can have
that all covered you're gonna have a
solution plan I mean I have the company
credit card so I'll just go ahead and
book the uh the kennel and the
babysitters and and all that I'm not
leaving my kids in dogs with ain't no
goddamn stranger who [__] some kind of
cow I don't know who that damn is
uh anyway okay but that's great news
many benefits don't see a lot of L's
there I'm just saying a lot of a lot of
Pros not a lot of cons guys I get it I
would like to go to Japan too I can't do
it y'all are single ass [__]
you don't know what my life is like you
don't think that your kids would love
dude you wouldn't love going on a trip
with my kids
okay you you just want to go you don't
want to hang out with everybody you just
want to go if if you and you and um if
you just want to go to Japan I'll fund a
trip you want to just go there by
yourself because if the kids yeah
totally fine yeah no I'll hit you up on
that no no no don't don't give up all
right well then uh I'm glad that uh you
have a nice salary so go enjoy your trip
it's just like funded it's like it's
like two things that I I now wish Ethan
would do one take steroids and two go to
Japan right you guys both of those are
so true I don't I said a long weekend I
said anything you guys want to do three
days
I'll pay for Fuji as possible [__]
first class I'm talking five-star hotels
no you gotta go you have to go I can I
have no desire
it's not that I don't want to go it's
that I can't do it I just can't do it
you know what I mean there's got to be a
lot of myself and you Ethan in the sense
that I also don't like traveling long
distances or leaving leaving the comfort
of my house that's not what I'm saying
I have two young kids
do you know how insane it would be to
travel with them there must be an
instance where parents have traveled
uh once at least once dude dude
it's not like a family vacation what
we're planning we're planning like we
all go and do like podcast stuff
together are you seeing it if the kids
come it'll become yeah in one piece
that's pretty dope oh that's pretty dope
wow this looks so this is top attraction
this looks so fun no this no this is
every corner how about how about this is
like your normal life just one piece
everywhere going to Japan especially as
someone who like loves anime and watches
anime going to Japan is quite literally
everything that weebs say it's like it
is like living in an anime 100 you're
walking down the street looking around
like and I hope you guys really enjoy it
when you go so I'm gonna be eating
you're gonna be running down the street
with a piece of toast in your mouth late
for your appointment yeah you're gonna
trip and have a funny encounter with a
quirky uh school girl no maybe that
sounds weird but back that up yeah
how about a talking cat or something
that's a 3 000 year old school girl
Danny you know how this works she's
three thousand year old but she looks
like she's eight she looks nine but
guys I know I can take I want I do would
love to take my kids on a family trip
but that's not what this would be I'm
telling you if we bring the kids it'll
be a whole [__] thing where it's just
about them you're tripping nah you're
tripping
uh North Korea
having an upper North Korea so North
Korea be awesome too but I think Japan
is probably a little bit cooler
so uh okay let's watch this let's watch
this I guess you know
that's great though that's exciting
thank you bbtv love that about you
Southern gun and truck loving dude yeah
beginning in March 2020. he started
painting his nails oh dude dude that's
how you know yeah show me your nails
right now we we're We're translating our
children
yay trads We're translating our does
brother also not and not at the moment
but like that was the one thing that
everybody like [__] absolutely would
like lose their minds over is like
whenever I painted my nails were like
are you gay you're so gay you paint your
nails you're gay it's like dude first of
all there's nothing wrong with that like
there's nothing wrong with being gay I
don't know why you're [__] freaking
out but secondly like no it doesn't work
that way also ironic because Chris here
is rocking the blue lives matter coat of
paint on there with the right
[Laughter]
Chris began to display increasingly
feminine traits dude I'm sorry that is
just so [__] dumb you literally just
showed this man with some paint on his
nails [__] tweets such as what year
is it my nails done at a nail tech
additionally Chris would highlight that
his facial appearance had changed
significantly since the start of the
pandemic which accompanied another post
reading okay so in four different
Customs let's just let's just
acknowledge the context this man is
making like a intense Thriller suspense
Style video about how this normal ass
dude decided to go trans and be true to
himself they're like 2 8 P.M Chris
pointed out his nails had changed color
to come next the next day at 11 PM Chris
said I'm feeling cute it's so weird man
people were concerned it's just like
being this obsessive about anyone
would immediately ring alarm bells for
like normal people but unfortunately
when you do it about trans people then
everyone's like nah that's normal like
we should all be just obsessive
psychotic perverts about uh trans people
like that's normal right guys come on
let's all do it together like that's
that's the attitude dude it's super
super weird and gross and [__] up I
had to prove I was myself because I'm
creepy it's creepy follow the trans
thing it's creepy and weird why is he
doing this you want to see I saw this
chart the other day uh and I can't
believe uh Hassan you've probably showed
it on your show or something before but
this was from a couple years ago
um and I feel like it's only like
massively ramped up since then yeah from
2021 and this is showing talk about
transgenderism oh that's on Facebook by
the ideological leanings
dude I say this all the [__] time Ben
Shapiro Matt Walsh daily wire freak all
the [__] losers in right-wing media
they care about trans people more than
trans people do they know about who the
latest and greatest like trans
influencer is like Dylan Mulvaney is a
great example of this right I don't know
who the [__] Dylan Mulvaney was yeah I
agree like I had no idea who the [__]
dilemovania was like I think she was
like popping on Tick Tock or whatever I
don't I don't know I don't go on Tick
Tock all that much I had no idea
she became a [__] known entity
because how much because of how much
right-wing media obsessed with her like
it's crazy it is absolutely insane they
follow everything that is going on in
the trans universe so they can like cut
propaganda off of it and it's so
obsessive dude and of course there's a
secondary component to it which is that
they're [__] Chasers like so many I
tell you man they're just like straight
up Chasers ladies you should be worried
if your husband talks about trans people
all day
yeah I mean definitely yeah for multiple
reasons yeah right or it looked nothing
like my pasta not the creepy music so
much that I'm considering updating my
passport do you see any resemblance
prompting replies such as that you went
from man to boy oh that's the guy this
is the guy who we were just watching
he's having like a full-on triggering
spasm over Mario
this is the guy that's Josiah Rises oh
the quartering phone yeah that was one
of the videos yeah you're totally right
he's like
Mario
that's where you guys found her yeah
Chris responded by stating now to be
honest I just really started taking my
mental health seriously and eating
better yet his Twitter photos kept
insinuating that Chris was becoming more
feminine with this same kind of look
showing up in his Mr Beast appearances
for example on the 6th of January 2023
Beast reacts uploaded a video titled
istrapped a GoPro to a fish in which
Chris dressed in a way that prompted
comments such as Chris yo look out look
what he's wearing dude are you freaking
kidding me right now
I just like
I I don't
sometimes I feel like in order to
understand the the right-wing mentality
on on issues like this I have to like
get a [__] Teflon pan and just like
bang my head to it right like just bang
on my head on a [__] drywall until I
bust through it on the other side so I
can like understand the right wing uh
attitude towards these sorts of things
bro I can kind of see through his shirt
a little bit so gay dude what the [__]
bro he's [__] he's wearing a necklace
ew necklace gross I either prompted
comments such as Chris has been adopting
more and more traits that remind me of
my grandmother okay is that a bad thing
I love Nana what about you say some
people just gonna ignore Chris's Nails
Chris had to have lost a bet the look is
getting Wilder the response to the video
then prompted countless viral tick tocks
such as this one with 700 000 likes
stating how did Chris go from this to
this While others even made the claim
that Carl had turned him gay
true dude
you know what we should I feel like I
want to watch this whole thing on Friday
and you're probably gonna watch it on
your stream yeah you want to savor it
you want to savor the content we can do
that yeah we'll save it
because I want to I I love that dude
yeah it's true Carl is yassifying our
children dude I want I don't know much
about Carl but I watched him stream a
little bit and I was like yo what the
[__] I'm feeling a little gay right now
yeah really yeah I was having gay
thoughts it's so funny because like uh I
ordered nail polish on Amazon but Carl
is is [__] hilarious I love Carl uh
he's hilarious I mean he's a thief uh
that's number one first and foremost
stole my streamy uh stole my [__] uh
multi-color pearl necklace and like
literally
took both of those things in North
Carolina I can never retrieve it any
longer okay so [__] you Carl
um never finished uh it takes two we
were supposed to play it we did it we
played it uh and then I understand you
guys are great friends no we're not
we're enemies it's good okay why because
he's yassifying our children
I'll tell you what man I got paint I got
even got paint now it's on my toes after
I seen Carl play Minecraft
yeah no it's it's really it's really
[__] dumb uh I can't wait to watch
this it's so funny
we must defend Chris at all cost video
on Friday yeah
may even make a donation to some trans
rights thing for my fat [__] stack of
money from bbtv yeah and then also
what's the best one the Trevor Project
is that a good one or is there a better
one it's a good one
a lot of a lot of these uh places have
like legal funds as well so they you
know they they work towards uh advocacy
amazing another good one
um so let's see let's I could just do
some news if we're gonna move on from
that
uh you did
actually to celebrate you here for a
minute
um I know a lot of people call you a
fake socialist because you make money
you make a lot of money
um yes this is this is true this is
gonna this is gonna throw a wrench in
their gears here apparently according to
Dextero sixerto dexerto highly reputable
yeah they got the yellow one steamed
journalistic Institute Hassan was one of
the biggest donators in the world to
Amazon labor unions
Financial disclosures filled last week
by the ALU shows the union raised more
than 850 000 last year more than half of
it from Just Three donors the American
Federation of teachers the international
commission for labor rights and the
leftist twitch streamer Hassan [__] and
all that tells me is just how [__]
these kind of movements are because like
there's so much money
you are I'm the George Soros baby but
first of all that's great good on you uh
because everyone calls you a fake
socialist but here it is right you're
donating a lot of money
the thing is like I
I didn't really talk about this when I
originally did it because
it's off of um
the unionized T-shirt uh t-shirt merch
uh that I took all the proceeds from
um it was also made domestically
manufactured by a union shop
I took all those proceeds and uh I put
it into the Amazon Labor Union fund
um obviously for those of you don't know
that's not like a 501c3 or anything it's
not tax deductible like in the way that
immediately people assume because
there's such [__] cynical weirdos
um but I didn't really talk about it for
two reasons well one because
um
you know it's not a big deal uh this is
one of the many I think it's cool this
is one of the many things I've done
throughout my career and the other
reason is like a little bit for
self-preservation like I have obviously
had Chris Smalls on the show
um you know I've I've uh I've done some
fundraisers uh alongside him for for
candidates that uh are that align with
our values
um but part of the reason why I didn't
like talk about it also was because like
I don't want
Amazon to catch wind of it you know yeah
because like I don't would they do that
I guess they're pretty ruthless I mean
they are pretty [__] ruthless I think
ultimately they think that it's probably
they well one they were probably not
familiar with it until this came out in
like a Business Insider article by the
way like this is not because they did
Financial disclosures as every Union
does at the end of the year and the
Business Insider did like kind of a hit
piece on them actually
um and a part of that also had the uh
Financial disclosures and it showed that
uh the union raised 850 000 last year
more than half of it came from the
American Federation of teachers the
international commission for labor
rights and me that's some sad
fundraising efforts right there boy but
there's no but but that's the the
reality is that like there is no
billionaire-backed project no I know
it's sad because ultimately we are all
we have and all of the funds that I have
at my disposal literally come from
people that are voluntarily giving me
five dollars a month in the form of a
subscription or uh or people purchasing
uh the the merchandise you know what I
mean so like
it's just there's no right-wing
equivalent to that like I'm not I don't
have like [__] factories uh that I am
exploiting uh overseas to to generate
millions and millions and millions of
dollars uh off of the backs of of uh the
you know the global South and then also
American uh non-union exploited uh
workforces that then I decide to dump
into uh the Federalist societies like
501c4 or whatever you know I I don't
have that
um all the all the money I make I still
make from uh people that watch me and
voluntarily choose to give me uh a
subscription revenue on which they don't
have to all my content is free
yeah I mean the union busting there's so
much money in that it is just a sad
reminder of just how stacked against the
the union and the labor
it is but uh
by the way sunnyv the guy who made the
video about Chris I knew he got two
video essays on my ass
h3h3's new content is awful
the disheartening downfall of h3a Street
Productions [__] free 3.5 million
views on that one oh yeah very [__]
nice bro if you go that Ethan hate
videos is like a whole industry yeah
they've got I mean I I have my own
version of that trust me I know yeah
yeah the uh Ethan and Ela everyone's at
least at one point favorite YouTube
couple okay I'll take that two of the
greatest content creators ever hit the
platform okay King let's stop reading
there this just sounds like compliments
I love the uh you know but [__]
guessing you up mate
he locked it yeah
I think so yeah okay
that's your ID yeah
uh they said he goes on he says
but two of the greatest creators that
ever hit the platform who have had their
reputation tarnished over the years but
the real question has his downfall been
Justified what downfall you see what
downfall because you don't like me
anymore I don't understand this downfall
narrative
he went woke and he went broke and I'm
like more successful than I've ever been
in my career six hundred thousand
dollars
right you had a damn full night which
means I don't want your [__] content
no more I didn't like the way that you
uh which means it's a [__] downfall
and what could have caused such a
downfall was it the change in their
personality from a chilled out couple to
an angry bitter pair of creators don't
put that on Ela I'm angry and bitter
don't that's my that's my favorite take
is like these guys who [__] sit there
and cook content like this will then
literally turn around and say that like
you're bitter now because I disagree
with you yeah like I disagree with your
world view so you're the bitter one
there was a time when I think I there
was a general bitterness but it wasn't
it was that they didn't agree with my
politics here he is is he gassing up
King there's no [__] shot he's
gasping hold on the unbelievable story
of keemstar and uh the disheartening
downfall I mean I'm getting a bias here
it's unbelievable okay
we're looking at two media careers I I
would feel like keemstar is in a bit of
a bit of a downfall mate
is putting it generously that man is is
a meteor in the ground he's just a
crater
uh has their downfall been Justified
has uh was it all owed to the H3 podcast
has their extreme rise in status caused
an arrogant personality
this is the rise and fall
it seems like you answered those
questions when you said fall
uh these are just my prob these are just
my problems with Ethan
and my opinion it's wild to see someone
go from one of the community's strongest
to one of the most out of touch and yeah
and your content is [__] off it's
[__] attitude
you've hit a dishoning downfall
he goes they shoot podcast has really
taken over the mindset of ethernet they
have disbanded their original style for
ad Revenue Teddy fresh and H3 merch
sales what the [__] you dummy stupid ass
here's keemstar by the way the
Incredible the Incredible career and the
unbelievable career of keemstar
oh he the last person to upload was some
random ass dude why would you hire
someone that looks like this stop dude
stop putting what do you mean he looks
like I know but he if he's looking for a
replacement also I don't think that's
him no no that's not him that's the son
I know who that is listen to me keemstar
looks like he looks he can't help it but
if he's in the pla if he's in the the uh
privileged position he's covering that
guy okay he's the immaculate Friday
Vibes guy who's like uh who was like
yelling at his twitch uh stream chat yo
Ethan I just looked yeah the last uh bit
of that guy's keemstar video is about
how is about your content nuke video
and how it's hopeless because keemstar
will never go away and his career will
always be strong like
everyone thinks I'm a racist I'm done
and I'm it's that's it you know you've
got to go to work every day you got to
make videos every day I've been shut
down like 15 times had to rebuild I just
never gave up dude back in 2009 so we
can see it here and highlight all the
terrible things that keemstar has done
for years like h3o3 did false
accusations racial remarks General
scumbaggery but I think sometimes we're
so busy hating him that we forget about
some of the good things he's done as
well think about it wait what like what
many weird things wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait I want to know what what
are the [__] good things mate all
right what's going on what's going on
there as well whoa whoa whoa go back go
back go back I gotta hear this whole
thing is this [__] brain working in
the opposite direction too mate but I
think sometimes we're so busy hating him
that we forget about some of the good
things he's
think about all the way you wish he
might have raised for domestic violence
as well as other ways
think of the awareness you raised for
domestic violence
from beating
well you did it no I don't think he did
it but that'd be kind of funny wait what
does he mean by that he repeated
awareness for domestic I mean just
covering drama when there was like
incidents between
there girlfriend yeah oh and by the way
wait doesn't he literally also
oftentimes like take the side of the
depending on like how he feels about the
person or if he's friends with him or
not doesn't he literally take the side
of the abusive person in certain I mean
oftentimes and cast out on the victims
oh I would say a hundred percent of the
time I don't think I think there were no
no we were entirely dependent on it's
entirely dependent on whether keemstar
personally likes you or not I think we
actually looked into if he's ever sided
with a uh victim a victim and I don't
think he ever has genuinely it's always
girls be lying girls be shopping no I
feel like he's one of those dudes every
right-wing dude does this where they
will just like take something no matter
how like ridiculous it might seem and
often will like jump to to defend the
accusation regardless if it's someone
that he doesn't like if it's like a
leftist you know what I mean like a
liberal
I can see him doing that I see a lot of
writing I think there probably are
examples but you're right it's it's
poisoned by him hating whoever he's
trying to make look bad so so go ahead
but she says oh he sent 500 one time to
this guy yeah I gave a hundred thousand
dollars you mentioned that he's [__]
a hundred thousand dollars you didn't
awoke why so it's a damn fall literally
I gave it to anybody and everybody it
wasn't a woke at all mate I did I picked
them totally randomly it's a downfall
Mike how's that a downfall yeah you
didn't [__] lift this Lee
is the age of consent
it's about you can either love him or
hate him but I think we all have to
unbiasedly admit that keemstar has had a
very impressive career on YouTube over
the last 11 years yeah he's maintained
relevancy
career I don't want to toot my own horn
but if I'm downfalled we're not saying
he's impressive the 15 times that
keemstar has been [__] personally
been banned off YouTube he's come back
in a very impressive Way by doing this
[__] quick scheme through drama alert
hey whether you like him or hate him you
got to admit the amount of people he's
made wanted made want to kill themselves
is pretty impressive it's quite
impressive life I mean how many people
can say that you're being a beat hat on
and one of them did let's be real I mean
I can't I can't stop I can't stop doing
the accent God damn it I would do that
if I could it's fine I'm [__] Puma
stuck he's like look at this dude who I
bought almost bullied into uh uh killing
themselves they're kind of ironic too
did you know Basher died of kovid I
don't know who this person is oh I was
deep because I don't know anything about
you this was a guy that keemstar
basically harassed for years and years
and years and he just destroyed him and
then he moved to Australia for like a
new life and he died of covid
rough I did not know that it was pretty
crazy
let's finish it there's only a little
bit despite waves and waves of hate I
think that's not often achieved by
others on YouTube
so inspiring man that's where right
before you screenshot inward Clips this
man is doing the n-word clip over
inspiring music no I think he's I think
he's like literally
yeah he this is like revealing his
perspective I think this is a bit of a
troll like he's basically saying like
keemstar is good there's nothing you can
do about it look at me [__] playing
him uh the clip of him like saying the
n-word play it let me see how it plays
out let me see
that's gonna be all for this video
though guys thanks man uh
yo that's it fire yeah the super cool
perspective when he said the [__]
inward I thought he's doing it in a good
way super Brave he's raising [__]
awareness
he said CREAM star said Blake lives
matter
when he said the n-word
he was ahead of the game mate raising
awareness for police brutality and
racism in America
shut up people are saying this is satire
it ain't that I don't I don't think that
that video ain't satire
I had the downfall and keemstar had an
Aspire inspiring uh also this video two
years ago which was before I mean he was
on the downside but before it like went
off the cliff like it has yeah I think I
think this dude
thought not much of a problem because of
his own personal biases he thought
keemstar is gonna [__] stay relevant
no matter what and and not become this
like drama farmer who's like desperate
for clicks but like not even doing
enough not even posting anymore yeah he
was too ashamed to post because it was
just sad
so maybe now that now that keemstar is
like you know defended trans people a
little bit on the timeline maybe sunnyv2
will make a damn full of keemstar Might
video you know I'm disabled star went
Vogue woke and then went broke my sonny
I'm giving you an opportunity to make
this right and make a new keemstar video
and also I'll expect a new video about
me just say listen I hate him and uh
he's a he's a libtard or whatever you
want to say but at least just say uh but
his career is okay I see a lot of people
don't like Ethan and that's totally fine
you don't have to like everything come
on you guys can I just live my life
let me just be the person I want to be
did you hear that Charlie defending me
against bbtv Play It Again I see a lot
of people don't like Ethan and that's
totally fine you don't have to like
everyone or anything yeah that's like
every time now anybody who's not like
explicitly left-leaning they go I
understand that you all hate Eaton I'm
gonna have him on the podcast on my
podcast uh this weekend I'm gonna go see
him and I'm gonna fall with him I'm
gonna [__] I'll dunk on them for you
where are you going to Career class yeah
oh yeah I'm going to find you need a
question yeah yeah you know maybe uh he
left last night yeah yeah we're having a
big ass uh watch party this watch party
that's right nice you're going yeah I'm
going
um and uh I'm gonna go to events like
that why oh you there's I guess there's
other twitch people there well that uh
you know I wanna I wanna show support to
uh my boys that are fighting the girls
that are fighting a lot of my friends
are fighting and also obviously Ian and
Anissa like they're they're great
they're wonderful
um I understand I look I under I
understand that most you guys hate Ian
and Anissa but I do want to say that
Creator Clash is a pretty good event so
let's just do it for at least for the
other people involved he he
it's not easy having 12 million uh
subscribers and consistently pump out
videos to get over a million views when
you're like direct the camera I you
gotta [__] tow the line and I think
Charlie is an interesting figure because
like he does do that he he fences pretty
aggressively but when push comes to
shove if he's not defending a content
creator that is on the left that he's
like he has to make a million qualifiers
for
um he he you know I mean I've heard him
talk about like labor rights against xqc
like aggressively defend labor that's
impressive yeah so like he's a very he's
a very interesting character but he did
ultimately uh defend me against pbtv on
on
um yeah no he was definitely you know
many people don't like Ethan he said a
downfall Sonny V2 actually did a pretty
good job of describing his [__]
downfall Ethan's career has tanked
harder than the bill Delphine porn video
after her only fans debut he made me
genuinely feel like than his dog [__]
but having said that watching and Ethan
videos like when my dog wipes its ass on
the carpet you know you dragged it
across the carpet and leaves a big [__]
stain and then I walk out and I slip on
the [__] stain and I crack my head open
there's blood pooling all over the place
just like that yeah I mean look like
watching in Ethan videos like wiping
your ass with toilet paper and the
finger goes through like you expect one
thing but you just end up fingering your
own [__] but then also it's a sudden
feeling of elation and feeling of
euphoria when that finger goes in your
butthole so then at least the positive
side to that whole experience even
though you have [__] in your fingernails
now right that's actually that's
actually I think we nailed it there you
go he said he said one positive thing
uh uh yeah but okay whatever
I do think if you watch those videos
it's kind of funny because it all really
just comes down to Ethan as woke now I
think right I mean ultimately yeah I
don't agree are they saying don't agree
with you I'm a hypocrite because I
changed my stance on things yeah and I'm
a sellout well it's also because like
they think that they are incapable of
change or they don't even want to so
they think when people change it's it's
from a cynical perspective because they
lack the imagination
it's it's always projection like they
just don't think that they are capable
of change uh and and therefore if anyone
has made that change genuinely it must
not be for a real reason it must be for
some other inexplicable Financial
component that that's the thing that I
don't get about like similar to the
Chris thing people go oh he's CH he's
going transfer clout it's like Chris has
literally everything to lose by doing
this the only possible explanation for
Chris doing this is because it was
really really really important to him he
has nothing to gain from doing that and
for me it was the same way
switching uh coming out more as a lib
and and stuff like that I had nothing to
gain from doing that it was all just
pain and suffering for years and years I
mean you were there dad
yeah yeah no there was definitely uh
there was definitely a lot of animosity
from uh sections of the audience that
were not down for that change but bro
like we said back in the show too they
came a lot of them came back around so
items items going through that as well
yeah like he's getting it rough and you
know he's just people [__] rip on him
so much obviously it takes
the the issue is like that kind of
growth and change also takes time like
obviously marginalized backgrounds are
not going to immediately turn around and
be like oh he said he's sorry okay I'm
on board you know what I mean it's gonna
take some time there will always be
people that will look back to what
you've done in the past and remember
that because
we don't just analyze things from the
outside especially well we do we're
white it doesn't impact Us in the same
way but if you're like a if you're like
a black teenager in predominantly white
spaces and all of these other like uh
all these other white kids were debating
on the right to say the n-word and like
making fun of you and whatever and you
grew up in that environment and you link
it in your mind not to like systemic
white supremacy and how pervasive that
attitude is but to like idubbbz's videos
then it's going to take a while for you
to come around and and maybe you might
never come around
damage that you experienced when you
were growing up it's something that I
see all the time my opinion on that is
I never expect anyone to forgive me for
anything you know I mean I just gotta
like be true to myself
make amends or try to try to acknowledge
the things that I've done wrong that
I've said that were wrong and you know
it's up to people if they want to
forgive or forget or whatever but like I
totally understand if there's things
that I've said or done that puts people
off forever that's fine you know I get
it
just gotta do what I do and uh
hope for the best that's what I'm gonna
thank some donators hey thank you for
the generous donation it's just a from
just a
yeah I gave a uh one of those animated
sticker things which uh canopy copy
pasted and Discord so
but we'll acknowledge 230 foreign
they donated quite a few times thank you
so much that might be actually someone
from bbtv who's just rounding up for me
uh the dynamic jab five gifted subs
thank you so much we love you oh that's
one of mine oh you know him dude I know
my chatter is everywhere the dynamic jab
thanks bro he's been a member for six
months so we love that for him all right
shout out and gifted five Nick Reyes
says hey Dan any reason why yesterday's
podcast never went on Apple podcast
there was a reason there was the
recording got corrupted and uh like our
local recording that we usually use to
put up
um so we had to default to the YouTube
version but the YouTube version took I
didn't mention this TV Ethan but it took
hours to process like hmm I mean it was
a long episode but usually it takes
about 20 minutes it took like three or
four hours but um I'll throw it up after
it's it's good now so I'll rip
yesterday's episode
make an audio version of it thank you
Nick or keeping Dan on his toes yes
thank you thank you Rory here's uh the
mole man says after the mandatory
viewing of the latest Mario movies the
original Mario movies is better of
course half the population of the
Fortress of the mole folk immediately
transgender oh no and the other half
became Alex Jones fan is this because of
covet colleague there's a Strife in the
mole of the whole Kingdom
thank you Rory uh resident mole person
Julie says I used to watch Basher and
Sky Does Minecraft that was my childhood
yeah dude that's gonna be rough for you
I don't know anything about that I don't
know who that is those are like old old
long time ago Minecrafters and they both
well bastard's dead
and does Sky Does Minecraft
I don't know but I don't think he's
doing well either but I don't know
uh Maggie says can I get a birthday
shout out for 25
. we could do one for 21.
close enough right
thank you Maggie we love you happy 25.
so uh anyway we basically covered
nothing in the document yeah
what do you think of Dalai Lama suck my
tongue oh my god dude what do you mean
well because I'm because this man lived
his whole goddamn life being pretty much
universally loved and at the he's almost
to the [__] Finish Line bro he's so
close wait wait 86 year old now they're
out to asking kids to suck his tongue he
was so close wait till you find out you
know Lord the son hates him okay let's
no that's not what I'm talking about
look up uh Dalai Lama CIA for more
information oh stop it Wait no that's
very much I'm gonna look it up
oh I'm looking it up even the Patek
Philippe that he talks about that FDR
gave him you know who gave him the Patek
Philippe it wasn't FDR directly it was
CIA agents that gave him the Patek
Philippe from fdu what is Patek Philippe
he's a famous [__] watch that he
always shows that FDR gave him he's like
uh you know this is one of my most
prized possessions the CIA gave it to
him Dolly the CIA openly why would he
want to watch from the CIA Declassified
all these documents so you don't have to
take my word for it you can literally so
what do you do with CIA I mean okay he's
friends with the CIA CIA was funding the
Tibetan uh nationalist movement because
yeah to [__] with China essentially yeah
part of our war our Cold War oh so he's
like uh he's like uh and then they gave
up agitate China and then they gave up
that's why it's like yeah they basically
did the the same like mujahideen uh
style
um like arm radicalize uh counter
propaganda movement in Tibet uh they
spent I think like at the time 1.6
million dollars this is all open this is
all government documents that have been
Declassified at this yeah not conspiracy
level it's not like uh it's not like a
conspiracy well so he fought against
China I mean yeah no yeah because China
at the time uh uh in in the 50s uh took
over or annexed to bed okay so so he's
fighting
the uh the previous uh serfdom that the
Dalai Lama and like the Tibetan uh
landlords and serfs uh had like the
prior construct in Tibet was
the Dalai Lama this current Dalai Lama
had 6 000 serfs in his life six thousand
oh he [__] he [__] them he [__] a
bunch of other like you don't go through
six thousand shirts without [__] at
least a dozen of them yeah he uh he had
six thousand serves which was like one
of the aspects they had like uh child uh
monasteries like they would just like
take children in the monastery oh God he
definitely did it he did all that
there's all that child monastery so
there's all that
stuff that uh you know the the at the
time uh
you know the the
Chinese Communists did not uh find to be
good
but I mean it was brutal it was a brutal
there was certainly a lot of brutality
on the Chinese end for sure so but it
seems like there is a suggestion that
this man has been uh sucking tongue for
a while well you remember your boy that
you had on your show that you uh that
that couldn't cure your Tourette's for
some reason boy your boy your homie oh
my boy yeah yeah Mexican guy uh the next
game guy yeah what would you say if I
were to tell you that the uh Dalai Lama
engaged in it I know play uh you know
legitimization operation of Nexium I the
way that I saw that first of all I'm not
defending the Dalai Lama I'm just saying
I know about that the way that I saw
that at the time is Dalai Lama does this
he does a whole like cross-country PR
tour and they're just one of the weirdos
that paid got a couple thousand and was
like yeah I'll suck your tongue yeah you
know you suck my tongue I suck your
tongue I get it
Tit for Tat type [__] so there it is uh
the Dalai Lama's been getting his Dolly
long no it'll go away I mean this is
like go away he's gonna die before this
goes away he's 86. no it'll go away in
the sense that like I don't
like I just there is so much media in
major media surrounding like uh the
Dalai Lama being a positive person from
Hollywood all the way to like major
media that they I didn't really see a
lot of coverage on this issue in the
media at all like there was a little bit
but it no one's talking about it now
yeah I guess it didn't make that big
away I am yeah I don't think they're
going to uh you know I don't think that
they're going to cover it all that much
it's going to go away no one's going to
care they'll probably a couple months
down the line talk about like uh you
know the the Chinese mistreatment of
Tibetan people and like their religious
oppression or something like that uh and
then and then people will be on the
Dalai Lama side again and some people
will say wait a minute didn't he ask a
child to suck his tongue like two months
ago and then they'll tell you shut the
[__] up you're a piece of [__] you just
love the Chinese Communist party and you
want every Tibetan to be murdered
ruthless
my favorite was people that were trying
to defend it by being like Oh that's
like a Tibetan
culture yeah you stick your tongue out
to tease people shut up yeah yeah and I
take my dick out to uh greet people it
wasn't it wasn't my dick it wasn't a
peace thing it was uh
the bad part was the sucking part yes
correct the tongue part nobody had a
problem
not a problem
uh yeah it's a it's a it's a formal uh
uh Ethan greeting to put out your dick
and say I think he's going Diane
Feinstein with it you know what I mean
he's just like his brain is melting he's
old as [__] and normally uh he would
probably control his urges in public uh
but now he's just uh he's just like a
little slipping a little bit he's
letting a little loose man you know let
the Dalai Lama have it Grandpa's feeling
keep your eyes on the keep your eyes on
the prize everybody uh China bad listen
uh young boy I have so much to teach you
at uh uh Tibetan uh program for kids
please join us
suck my tongue
I'll please join the ranks of three
thousand serfs of little young boys like
you
I promise I will not [__] you okay they
don't have it no more to be fair all
right it's been two hours we've covered
nothing oh yeah
which means we're ready for next week
but I had a good time I'm so tired man I
don't know what's going on with me but
have a good night have a good night it's
these early ones I just I can't do it
it's not that early you did do it I have
been doing it for like a year a hell of
a show buddy thanks bro good show she's
gonna do it did you hit the button I
thought you said it's disconnected it is
yeah I was just kidding okay
just making sure you know that I've been
doing it yeah yeah yeah
just a joke
I was like is it not disconnected no no
you're good you're good yeah so hi sin
a real socialist a a donator fake fake
champagne champagne nope nope nope this
is the real deal folks he's out here
donating money
and uh he says I'm skinny dude please
don't fire me Jeff Bezos I'm sorry I'm
sorry but in a way he is funding the
Union
no no no not at all let's stop talking
about this oh but you could always come
to YouTube and you I don't want to lose
my yeah but you know I like being on
Twitch yeah but if you get banned
because Jeff Bezos is mad that'd be such
a great story
no no let's let's do the outro let's do
come on
no no I think it'd be good if yeah I'm
happy I don't
bye everybody
foreign